- [Narrator] Now the dust has
settled on Stranger Things 3
we thought you might
need a little something
to channel your obsession
with the iconic cast.
Here's a list of things you might not know
about the actors who play
your favorite characters
from the show.
(80's pop music)
Let's start with Eleven
herself, Millie Bobby Brown.
Before her breakout roll
Millie guest starred
in Grey's Anatomy, Modern Family,
and Once Upon a Time in Wonderland.
- I promise to bring it back, all right!
- No, that's what you said
about my mom's humidifier!
- [Narrator] Millie is
partially deaf in one ear
and when she's performing
she can't fully hear herself.
She often couldn't hear when
the director yelled "action"
on set unless it was really loud.
(screaming)
(window breaking)
Her first ever kiss was on
the set of Stranger Things
with on-screen boyfriend Finn Wolfhard.
Speaking of Finn, did you know
that he first auditioned
for Mike while sick in bed?
Where do we get that kind of discipline?
- Boom, boom, boom!
- [Narrator] It might come
from his film-centric family.
His older brother is an actor
and his dad is a screenwriter.
When he's not acting
Finn plays with his rock band, Calpurnia.
♪ And nobody wants to know you now ♪
- [Narrator] He's not the only
musician in the cast though.
Gaten Matarazzo used to be in his own band
called Work in Progress.
♪ Turn around, look at what you see ♪
- [Narrator] Gaten was the
first of the party to be cast
landing the role of Dustin even though
he originally auditioned for Mike.
He was born with a condition
called cleidocranial dysplasia
which affects bone and teeth development.
The Duffer brothers adapted
the role especially for him.
- Trust me, no collar bones, remember?
- Uh, excuse me?
- Oh he's got some disease.
It's crydo...something, yeah I don't know.
He's missing bones and stuff.
He can bend like Gumbo.
- [Narrator] Before he
starred in Stranger Things
he was a sweet Broadway
babe with roles in Les Mis
and Priscilla Queen of the Desert.
He's not the only Broadway
star in Hawkins though.
Caleb McLaughlin played young Simba
in the Lion King for two whole years.
He also studied dance at the
Harlem School of the Arts
with one of the Lion King's
original cast members.
♪ Look at what you see ♪
- [Narrator] Caleb
revealed in an interview
that he's a real germaphobe.
Not ideal for venturing
into the Upside Down.
On the subject of the Upside Down
let's talk about someone who
knows a few things about it.
Noah Schnapp, who plays Will Byers.
Born in 2004 he's the
youngest member of the party
with only eight month's difference
between him and Millie Bobby Brown.
He's been acting since
he was just six years old
having starred in Bridge
of Spies, the Peanuts Movie
and the Angry Birds Movie.
- Sometimes I wonder if
the kids really like me.
- [Narrator] He may be
one of the younger members
of the cast but he is older than someone.
His twin sister Chloe, by four
minutes but it still counts.
He doesn't technically
have an on-screen sister
but he does kind of have
an on-screen sister in law
in Natalia Dyer who plays Nancy Wheeler.
Did you know that her first acting role
was playing a fan in the
Hannah Montana Movie?
(screaming)
The Best of Both Worlds
written about the Upside Down?
Confirmed.
Both on and off screen
Natalia is dating co-star Charlie Heaton.
Charlie, like most of
the rest of his co-stars,
is a musician and plays the drums.
He's also the only one in the main cast
to have his own baby IRL.
Cute!
Someone else who knows a bit
about having a famous parent
is Maya Hawke, AKA Robin,
who is the daughter
of Hollywood legends Uma
Thurman and Ethan Hawke.
Before joining the cast she
stared in the 2017 adaptation
of Little Women playing the same character
as co-star Winona Ryder
in the 1994 version.
Maya has already modeled
for Vogue and Calvin Klein
and this is all before her breakout role.
Another cast member who's
no stranger to modeling
is Mad Max herself, Sadie Sink.
She strutted down the catwalk
at Paris Fashion Week in 2018.
At just 17 she has already
played Annie on Broadway,
a young Queen Elizabeth on stage,
and guest starred on the
Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt.
- Elena, you try, his head is perfect.
- Wait, wait, wait, look
I know you're acting out
but it's probably just problems at home.
- What did you say about our homes?
- Oh I didn't know!
- [Narrator] Meanwhile, Joe
Keery played Ferris Bueller
in a Domino's commercial back in 2017.
(80's pop music)
- Get that pizza.
- [Narrator] We love it.
He's another one that plays
in a band called Post Animal.
So when's Stranger Things,
the musical dropping?
Dacre Montgomery who plays
Billy would absolutely be down.
The Australian has his own podcast
where he performs beat poetry over music
from different artists.
- [Dacre] My body is so spent
dripping sweat, kitchen
sink, blood on my teeth
aching minds, splitting
skulls, sleepless nights.
- [Narrator] So there you have it.
Just a few facts about the actors
who play your favorite
characters on the show.
Oh, and one more bonus fact.
The cast have a group chat
called Stranger Texts.
Um, how do we get an invite?
Know any more facts about the cast?
Leave them in the comment's below.